all right Tallulah this weirdly feels
like your Hollywood coming out because
it's like your first big I'm Tallulah
thing
and it makes sense that it's space
themed I'm in a metallic trench coat and
everyone is accepting the absurdity of
it all I 100 make sense why was this the
the way you wanted to kind of
reintroduce yourself to the world
uh that actually was a byproduct of just
saying yes to something that I thought
was kind of wonderful and that's kind of
how I'm choosing to navigate
any and all projects that come my way
you know if it's meaningful heart
centered wonderful if it can have impact
um
and and you know if if it if it kind of
hits any of those
notches then then I I say yes and and
this is uh one this you know it's a
wonderful side effect uh that I'm I'm
really happy with and
um like I've made wonderful friends in
this experience I've been able to
chat with wonderful people
um and and this is a great and really
lovely intimate Affair you know and
having grown up this is not my first
launching of a something party but this
is actually a very sweet and tender and
really feels connected to what we did
and that's how the whole experience of
the show was
it's like a little family reunion
tonight
desperate to go see my friends what who
did you bond with the most from this
group I would say
everyone
[Music]
got tracks yes we really really bonded
um me and Natasha really bonded and then
really me me and everyone me and
Marshawn had a very wonderful unexpected
camaraderie and friendship Bloom and but
it's like you can't even pick one out
because
what happened very quickly is that
everyone created
this this
Network this this kind of flowing amoeba
of this unit you know and and it really
felt
like I I literally said my you know my
mom and I wrote her
um I I said how was it and I said you
know there was not one kind of kind of
uncomfortable personality like literally
everyone meshed and that was so lovely
what did you learn about yourself in
going to Australia cosplaying as Mars
bravery shows
shows in many different ways
that my type of Bravery
is very beautiful but it's not
necessarily super efficient in a
timed action-centered gotta get it done
kind of way and that's okay because I'm
a Vibes person and I bring some really
good vibes and I make people feel good
but I don't know if I'm the best at like
you gotta go over it now yeah and that's
okay but no I'm not good at that
all right that's what you learned about
yourself what do you hope the viewers
learn about you from watching you
I think that
I've
really presented and as I've hoped to
really come across
um
very honest and very raw
um and and a lot of the things that I've
experienced in my life and that is a
huge part of who I am and another huge
part is I'm
I have the weirdest sense of humor and
I'm act like I'm just I make jokes all
the time and but it's like very
fast-paced and wig odd and like it's
like constantly like a comedy shtick is
going and I think because this is a
situation where I've been filmed and I
genuinely forgot the cameras were there
because they they really did them
dressed them nicely I let my guard down
and so I am really excited because I
don't remember what I said or what I did
that I hope that it's funny like I want
to re-lap with myself you know because I
know we laughed and so that's what I
really hope they see it's just like the
goofiness
the Vogue essay so beautiful the
response I think has also been beautiful
what do you hope the takeaway was for
people from that
I mean the response has been so
unbelievable and I'm incredibly grateful
um not only for the people that have
reached out but for Vogue and Anna and
Rob and everyone that was a part of
getting that
um
out there and
I think that
for me I hope that whatever anyone
needed to take from that
they can take from it I don't I don't
necessarily want to dictate what they
needed to take from that I think that
that's their that's their truth and and
that I just hope that there can be more
moments that I can help open up the
space for things to resonate for people
what was your family's response when
they read that
they were very proud of me
I have to say it's really beautiful how
you all have walked through a very tough
time in your life
is there anything you want the world to
think about as you continue to walk this
path
that
as with every person and every moment
that there is
so much power in kindness and patience
and compassion
and I think that can be true for every
person at every moment you know and it
doesn't matter or it doesn't necessitate
um
sadness or grief or loss but obviously
those those things you know can it can
help in those moments
um but I think those are really
important things to always live by
it's okay to feel a lot of things at
once
[Music]